وماجي هامرمان معنا الآن
هي أيضًا مؤلفة كتاب ثقة الرجل الذي
صنع دونالد ترامب
وكسر أمريكا ماجي ، نبدأ مع
المرحاض ، أخبرنا بما تعلمته ،
صباح الخير يا رفاق ، شكرًا
لاستضافتي حتى كنت أقوم بالإبلاغ  لقد
علمت في هذا الكتاب أن الموظفين في
منزل البيت الأبيض سيجدون بشكل
دوري المرحاض مسدودًا ،
وسيتعين على المهندس أن يأتي ويصلحه
وما سيجده المهندس سيكون عبارة عن
رزم منكم تعلمون أنها مكتوبة بأوراق مطبوعة مبللة
أم تعلمون  مما يعني أنه لم
يكن ورق تواليت ، كان هذا
إما ملاحظات أو قطعة
ورق أخرى تعلمون أنه يعتقد
أنه ألقى في المرحاض ما
يمكن أن يكون بريانا يمكن لأي شخص أن
يخمن أنه يمكن أن يكون لاحقًا - يمكن أن يكون
ملاحظات  كتب لنفسه أنه يمكن أن تكون
أشياء أخرى لا نعرفها ، لكنها
بالتأكيد تضيف بعدًا آخر كما قلت
لما نعرفه عن كيفية
تعامله مع المواد في البيت الأبيض
الذي عرفناه لعدة سنوات  منذ أن
كسرت زميلي آني كارني قصة
أن ترامب كان يمزق قطعًا من
الورق وأن موظفيه كان عليهم
إعادة لصقها معًا لأغراض الأرشفة
،
فهذه هي الطريقة التي تعامل بها مع المستندات
والقطع الورقية طوال حياته من حيث
تمزيقها  لكن كان هذا شيئًا
كان هذا شيئًا مختلفًا ولم
يكن أه كما قيل لي أن هناك حادثًا منفردًا
عدة مرات كانت المجلات شيئًا
كانوا سيجدونه بشكل دوري
ليكون كذلك أه أنت تعرف الرقم الدقيق
جون أنا  لست متأكدًا من ذلك ، ولكن
لم يكن الأمر كذلك لمرة واحدة وكان مرحاضه كما لو
كان مرحاضه
في الأنابيب ، أعني أنه كان في
الأنابيب وأه وكان هذا كان هذا
كان هذا حمامه لذا نعم